I may not know karate but I know belissa
be a crazy I said up élisa élisa élisa
and her hubby Dan are now neighbors we
live in the same complex and they did go
to the hospital recently they don't have
crap so she's welcome to sit as close to
me as she wants today we're gonna watch
together from the channel cartoon
hooligans
spider-man's pickup lines hence the tape
this is cartoon stuff I wanted to shout
out Alyssa be crazies twitch right at
the top tell them about it Alyssa make
it fast
I do a lot of variety I do a lot of
gaming but I also do a lot of art
streams because I do a lot of art
Commission's and I do those Commission's
on the stream sometimes and that's a
good time now when I remind you to bring
it up again and in the later video you
better say that with a lot more
confidence oh okay I'm sorry I have
issues with self-confidence well we're
gonna solve that today oh it takes ten
minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
hey mr. Sark
hello beer well you know how I've been
really awkward around girls I was
wondering if you could teach me a thing
or two about talking to them oh really
[Music]
yes every single time 100 this is
awesome Thank You mr. stark
now go memorize them all once you do
he's such a precious baby hello let me
introduce myself again
I'm Peter oh hi I'm Natasha no you're
not
excuse me you're not Natasha you're
gorgeous
[Music]
they have no is spider-man and yours Oh
people call me Black Widow I don't like
that name
can I call you something else what what
do you want to call me I want to call
you mine fury just fired me from the
Avengers oh my god that's horrible
why would he do that they said I have
mental health issues
why because I'm meddling there's
something wrong with my phone what's
wrong it doesn't have your number let me
show you a lovely picture of me and my
girlfriend oh okay lovely right okay
Loki those nuns at work do you know what
bears like to eat the most
honey yep and you know every time I see
you
[Music]
you're from Russia right yep that's
right perfect
I like my women to be like vodka strong
bitter end
deadly I mean you even old enough to
drink yet no not yet my cities fireproof
what about yours yeah it's fireproof -
thank God
who else you'd be too hot to handle
[Music]
thank you
huh your rental bill what rent I'm
charging you rent for spending too much
time on my mind
[Music]
Oh what's wrong - the hospital this
morning what did the doctor say doctor
said I'm lacking vitamin you Natasha
Romanov you're under arrest
hold on a second Oh what have I done
wrong it is illegal to let this
beautiful
[Music]
that's great but I realized I couldn't
oh why because I've already given you my
heart that's like something that would
be on those old like first or second
grade like yeah yeah what do you mean
what does it feel like to be the most
beautiful girl in this room my god do
you know what is the most romantic
number nine no oh
45 nah two thousand five hundred and
sixty one seventy two thousand nine
hundred thirty-eight No
1 million two hundred and twenty four
thousand five hundred ninety-one no it's
five five yes come on you gotta fall for
this at least one time Natasha this is a
really really good one oh man poor Peter
that's how Dan got ELISA you know I
thought I'd seen this channel before but
I don't think I have actually I think
it's my first time watching these guys
no same it's like it feels like it's
something that should be on like
late-night Cartoon Network Ryder it's
got a bit of a Teen Titans go vibe oh
yeah yeah and I thought it was so funny
because all of Peters pickup lines like
I thought they're all gonna be a bunch
of like Marvel or superhero puns but you
could swap out like a whole bunch of
other characters from all different
kinds of comedians it still apply for
the same kind of tracks they were poor
guy just can't catch a break it's true
these ladies have no sense of humor
whatsoever I'd be like look you are not
supportive a woman that's what I got
from this video
I don't want to have to be the one to
defend women who get hit on why is this
becoming about this ELISA
all I'm saying a shoot your shot the
worst that can happen if she says no
okay what I loved about it was every
time he sweated there was actual sweat
coming out of his mask and some of these
pickup lines were just genuinely
hilarious like these are things that
they would have totally worked on on my
girlfriend well like many years ago each
every single one of these she falls for
this kind of crack if you ever meet my
girlfriend in person she will leave me
for you if you use any of these lines
same thing with ELISA oh yeah except for
with me there's legal junk now that
makes it even more exciting people and
the animation do also kind of reminded
me of I don't know but just because of
the red hair will Black Widow I'm sorry
gets on like impossible vibes just a
little bit some of it some of that
animation style and the voice work I
thought was really great too
I heard pickup lines at him I feel like
really dirty yeah thank God okay here's
the because I do like really dirty or
really really corny but I didn't think
these for that corny they're just silly
and fun and I loved it yeah Tony Stark
really doesn't know what he's talking
about that's what I learned from this I
don't think he took into consideration
that he was already famous so when he
dropped these lines you know these
ladies would already know he's like a
multi-millionaire so of course they're
gonna work a correction Billy
billionaire I'm sorry
millionaire first now I got it's okay
for guys to approach women repetitively
and say uncomfortable lines to them as
long as they're just keep trying
women will fall for men with money Wow
Wow that's what I got in this video and
if you are Tony Stark levels of wealthy
you can't be surprised at the concept of
gold diggers showing up oh no like
average people like me for that and
that's why she married Dan
alright guys well evidence already
subscribe to cartoon hooligans so go
check out Alyssa be crazy stretch
channel subscribe to the real rejects
click the notification bell we'll see
you guys soon
you